Grilling season has arrived.
Are you ready? If not, you're going to be.
Here is a real party pleaser for your backyard gathering...
...that makes you look like MacGyver and a true backyard chef.
Go digging in your garage or basement for an old clay pot.
Next, you're going to need some type of surface to cook on.
I used this little grate I found in my scrap metal pile,...
...but you could just as easily use any metal that'll hold some food.
I trimmed around it with my scissors for a snug fit inside.
You're going to want to carefully line the pot now...
...and make sure to cover the hole at the bottom.
So, bust out that tinfoil and cover it up.
Get your charcoal and fill the pot up about two inches from the top.
Now, light it and lay your grill top back on.
You are going to want to give the charcoal about ten minutes to heat up and then it's go time.
Toss down your favorite grillables and save the day...
...with your ingenious improvised terracotta grill.
Now, keep in mind you can control the heat levels...
...by putting the top of the pot back on.
Just leave a little room for air to get in there or it's going to go out on you.
Looks delicious and clean up's a breeze; just toss out the foil.